i got a question for you so you said
luck hard work intuition if you were to
you seem like you're a data guy for sure
you're a data guy what would you say
percentage wise because a lot of people
say it's 80 luck some people say it's 80
hard work what would you say with your
experience uh
i don't know 60 40 to be different 60
luck
uh hard work 60s hard work harder you
work the luckier you get okay so fine
that's the truth and then where you put
intuition
very important in my case it was uh
paramount importance you know you gotta
go with your gut and i tell these young
people today i do a lot of talking at
colleges you know basically uh
you gotta basically have good intuition
you have to have good judgment you can't
teach that though
no but
listen
all throughout life we all have setbacks
and what makes a success is how you
handle those setbacks i've had my
setbacks and i came roaring back
what's your biggest one
well i hired a guy at a goldman who
turned out to be a crook and uh
violated the foreign corrupt practices
act uh and implicated the implicated the
firm
we knew nothing about it
the government is a bunch of criminals
because they try to you know they don't
want to know the truth they just want to
basically embarrass you
and i had to fight through that and i
won
in the end but it was very very
difficult situated very costly i had a
billion dollars of capital left the firm
but you know we came back
that's the comeback so question in
regards to capitalism you've been around
for a while and you've seen how media
presents the wealthy
uh socialists are not a new thing
they've been around for a while they've
been doing this for a while i saw one of
your quotes in this article
uh with what do you call it with uh
wahpo that you did and the other
gentlemen that did the universe which i
thought was pretty fair you said one
quote here
you said capitalism has flaws but
socialism has no benefits well i quote
uh winston churchill he said the main
vice of capitalism and even distribution
of prosperity the main vice of socialism
is the equal distribution of misery one
of my other heroes in life is ken
langone who's one of the finest
type of europeans fabulous guy if you
haven't read his book you've got to read
it i love it i i read it i read it you
know he and i have a lot in common his
father was a plumber in long island my
dad was a plumber in the bronx
and i i think the world of ken and ken
says he'd like to take his private plane
and fly these young kids that think
socialism is superior to capitalism to
venezuela and cuba and see what it's all
about i went to cuba about six or seven
years ago in a mission
and you know it takes three hours to get
from the out from the suburbs to
downtown
uh to get to their work because they
have no organized transportation system
their cell phones of course i think
three dollars and 85 cents a minute this
is five years ago they all drive around
1955 chevrolet
3.45 cents a minute 3.85 three a minute
five years ago five years ago
and they can't afford it and they're the
only capitalists in the country are the
hookers
wow
i live i lived in venezuela i mean i was
i was witness to the craziness before
chavez came on and you know there's
something to be said about
you know how desperate people get when
there's an inequality divide in the
united states like there is but that's
not the solution
not the solution at all you know what
most will change though what i'm trying
to find out with you is so 25 years
goldman 25 years omega 1966 is when you
took the job offer with 12 500 with 15
rate growth over five years you'll make
25 000 and i'm assuming you made it i
made 180 000 in the fifth year great so
ninth year they have that big you know
you become a partner 40 million dollars
and then 1.8 billion dollars you've been
through the whole ride as you went
through and then start your own company
the relationship between the capitalist
and media and the youth there's always
been a relationship right more poor
people than rich people and the
politicians like to play that up i had
this battle with elizabeth warren who i
consider a politician
in the worst sense of the word so i gave
a speech at a uh conference about three
or four years ago
at a time when she was running strongly
in the polls and the moderator asked me
what do i think the market would do if
elizabeth warren won
i said we'll go down 20 percent
next day not knowing anything about me
she tweets leon i'm only looking for two
percent there's the wealth tax which is
complete [ __ ] uh give others a shot
the american dream so i think long and
hard and i decided to you know michelle
obama made a comment when they go low we
go high and i send her a very very good
five-page letter which i recommend if
you don't have you get it
in fact it was so good
that larry summers
who's a liberal economist and a very
bright man
calls me up and says you know if you
submit that paper in the class i gave it
harvard i'd give you an a plus not an a
plus
what does she write next day
no doesn't address anything i wrote in
the letter which was very respectful
very balanced i thought we all got to
work together to fix the problem she
comes back and says inside trader when i
had this
problem with the government i won the
case and owned stock and navient which
was irrelevant to the situation she
doesn't like student loan companies
and
made no attempt to address the substance
of my letter and so i look as a
politician the worst sense of the word
then a year later she invites me to fear
me before one of the committees in
washington i turn it down and she says
on tv that i was afraid to meet with her
i wrote another letter i said i'm not
afraid to meet with you but i sent you a
very serious letter where basically
somebody commented was an a plus paper
and a liberal economist and you dissed
it never responded to it i'll meet you
in any program on tv uh to debate you
what's how do you get to be a
billionaire in the economy you know
basically you get to be a billionaire
you develop a product or service that
the world needs and you get rewarded for
it and most billionaires i know give the
money back to society
you know and uh i love telling the story
i'm very friendly with bernie marcus who
lives in my community in florida and you
know bernie i think was terminated by
sandy siegeloff on a wednesday night he
calls up ken langone in tears saying i
got three kids a big mortgage i have no
income and then who's a
tough guy yes he says what the hell are
you moaning about i'll raise your money
you'll open your superstore so he gets
40 families to put up 50 000 each raises
two million dollars the market cap of
home depot today is over 300 billion
dollars
ken and bernie have given away billions
of dollars to
charity both i think have taken the
giving pledge with buffett uh there are
three thousand employees at home depot
that are worth over a million dollars as
a result of stockholm it's amazing if
you could explain to me what's wrong
with that picture you know i i believe
in the progression you're going fast
folks i don't know if you caught that
over 3 000 employees who have a net
worth of a million dollars because of a
capitalist got together and did this
please continue yeah and so you know you
broke my train of thought but basically
no he said what are you crying for
here's the money now there's 3 000
millionaires yeah yeah
but basically i'm saying if you tell me
what's wrong with that picture the world
is better up because of bill gates jeff
bezos and larry ellison and bernie
marcus they're amazing employers yeah
you know what's crazy in that book i
love capitalism i recommend it to a lot
of people there's a story he tells i
think i want to say ken's dad died at 62
years old maybe 63
and he says his dad died
from a basic we could have saved him he
says i've been on blood thinners i don't
know how long he's been on blood
thinners he says i've been on blood
thinners since 50s or since i was 60. he
says if capitalist capital because of
capitalism we now have blood thinners
where my dad would have lived an
additional 20 years because i think ken
is in his 80s right now late 70s early
30s 85 85 yeah so think about a
capitalist creates a business he's in
great shape though because he goes to
gym every day he goes to church every
day
he's he's the largest guy he's a very
unique guy he's a very special human
being if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]